hey how're you doing tonight folks in
this video I want to continue my review
of the plot leak and in this video I'm
going to go over episode 2 so I'm going
to read the entire episode and then I'll
break down each section of it and talk
about what I believe and what I don't
believe and you know the type of things
that should happen or I don't see will
be likely at all to happen so let's
begin in episode 2 the plot leaked
States John gets a raven from Daenerys
telling all the northern Lords to meet
her on Dragonstone to parlay John and
Davos decided to go ask for some of the
dragonglass stock powder on Dragonstone
Sansa is left in charge of Winterfell
and John leaves ghost behind to Dorne
and Highgarden get sacked by the
Lannisters early in the season
Jaime confronts Olenna Tyrell at
Highgarden
she tells Jaime everything about how she
and Littlefinger poison Joffrey Jaime
allows her to drink poison and kill
herself before being captured Euron's
fleet destroys yara Greyjoy's and takes
her prisoner Theon escapes by jumping
overboard and is rescued by other
Ironborn Joran Greyjoy attacks Dorne as
well
killing two sand snakes and capturing
ilaria okay so let's start with the
first part of this it says John gets a
raven from Daenerys telling all the
northern Lords to meet her on
Dragonstone to parlay John and Davos
decide to go to ask for some of the
dragonglass stockpiled on Dragonstone
okay now this seems pretty likely we
definitely know John and Daenerys we're
going to meet up at some point in the
show and with all the photos that I've
been leaked as they're filming season 7
we already see that that's definitely
going to take place next season so that
definitely makes sense that John and
Danny meet up with each other and
discuss and strategize about how you
know Danny is going to get this Iron
Throne and what John's role is going to
be in that is he gonna stand by her and
help her or is he gonna poseur but
another thing that I thought of before
this leak even came out as soon as I
thought that Dany could be on
Dragonstone I'm
mediately thought well if she does ask
John to come there he definitely needs
to see about all the dragonglass that's
there because we know stan has already
said that there is plenty there to be
mined basically as much as you could get
out of there is there so it seems like
there could be an unlimited amount of
dragonglass at Dragonstone
so if John has an opportunity to go
there he might as well try and get some
while he's there so that definitely
makes sense that he would want to do so
because he definitely knows he needs it
because he lost all the dragon class
that he had back in hardhome when he
tried to go back into the little shed
there you know rescue it that's when the
white Walker came in and attacked him
and he didn't have a chance to get it he
basically had to leave it behind her he
would have died trying to save it so the
first part of that makes a lot of sense
and there's already a bunch of photos
that have came out to back that up
nothing about the dragon glass yet but
we can assume what John's there he's
definitely gonna want to get some and it
says Sansa is left in charge of
Winterfell and leaves ghosts behind to
now just by the photos that I've came
out that seems to be true so far because
we haven't seen Sansa in any of the
photos with John and Davos at
Dragonstone so it doesn't appear like
she left Winterfell at all and we know
that they really don't use the
direwolf's in too many episodes so
that's a way for them to leave ghosts
out of the equation and not have to
explain why he's not in every single
episode it would make sense for Johnny
leave ghosts behind with Sansa to give
her some extra protection while he's not
there to look over her so that kind of
kills two birds with one stone it gives
Sansa the protection that she needs
while John's gone in all the scenes that
they're going to be showing John with
Daenerys they're not going to have to
explain why ghost isn't there we'll just
be known that he's back in Winterfell
with Sansa so I could see why they would
do that and it also says born in
Highgarden gets sacked by the Lannisters
early in the season
Jamie confronts Elena Tyrell at
Highgarden
she tells Jaime everything about how she
and Littlefinger poison Joffrey Jaime
allows her to drink poison and kill
herself before being captured okay we
definitely know by the photos in all the
reports that the Lannisters definitely
sack Highgarden next year there's plenty
of photos to kind of back that up
there's a new castle that they've
already been showing that already has
the Lannister flag planning at the top
so if this is not Casterly Rock then it
is indeed
Highgarden and the Lannisters definitely
won that battle and there was also a new
report that came out today
that I haven't had a chance to talk
about yet but I'm going to talk about
right now is that the tarly's actually
are not going to be fighting with the
Tyrells next year they're actually going
to turn their back on the Tyrells and
fight with the Lannisters
and I haven't noticed it in any of the
photos that I have but it's said in a
report that there was a photo that
showed the tarly's marching side-by-side
with the Lannisters so I haven't seen
that photo yet to confirm it but that's
pretty damn interesting so that just
makes the Lannisters forces that much
larger and they have another great
commander on our side with randyll Tarly
so that could definitely change the
entire dynamic of what's going to happen
in that battle when the Lannisters do go
up against Daenerys and all her forces
so that's pretty interesting so keep an
eye out for that
if the police turn her back on the
Tyrells that could really really spice
[ __ ] up next year but it says the
Lannisters also sacked Dorne which I
don't think that's likely I really don't
have a lot of information to support why
I believe that but we already know the
Lannisters are involved in two big
battles next season when they take over
Highgarden and as they're marching back
they get attacked by Danny into the
track II and the unsullied so I don't
know if they have the Lannisters in
three battles next year especially with
none of those battles being against you
know Jon Snow and in-company
I just don't really see the Lannisters
going to Dorne and attacking Dorne as
well but I could be wrong they could be
trying to just completely eradicate the
whole Dorne storyline because they know
they completely screwed that part of the
story up and they know fans have been
outraged about how they made those
characters look on the screen compared
to how they are in the books so this
could be the opportunity that they want
to take to just completely get rid of
that storyline so I guess I could see
them willing to do that which would also
explain what else it says is going to
happen in this episode when you
are on attack storm and he kills to the
sand snakes that could be them just
trying to wipe that whole part of the
story out what's personally I hope they
do I didn't like Dorne at all so to see
that part of the story gone just makes
me happy I do not want to waste any more
time with scenes with the sand snakes or
ilaria so the faster they wiped that
part of the story out the happier I will
be I know some of you probably disagree
but this is just how I feel
now another thing that kind of I didn't
really like is how it says olena Tyrell
drinks poison to kill herself
I could kind of see her doing that but
she's been such like a great figure in
the show and she's been so tough I just
don't see her going out like that by
committing suicide I definitely could
see why she'd want to tell Jaime
she helped poison Joffrey just to kind
of stick that knife in his side because
you know Jaime's sister murdered her two
grandkids so I could see why she'd want
to let the Lannisters know okay you guys
might have hurt me there but guess what
I killed Joffrey so [ __ ] you so I could
see her what wanting them to know that
she's the one that did that but I just I
don't see her wanting to kill herself to
go out like that I think she got and a
lot tougher away than that
but I could be wrong as well you know
what I mean who knows how she dies I
just I don't know I wouldn't want to see
her go out by suicide I'd like to see
her go out you know in a much more
honorable way basically so give me your
thoughts on that but it says you're ons
fleet destroys your Greyjoy's takes her
prisoner theone escapes by jumping
overboard and is rescued by other and
Ironborn okay we knew at some point
Euron was definitely going to go toe to
toe with his niece and nephew the last
time we saw him he said he wanted to
murder both of them for taking off with
his ships when he became king so we knew
at some point they were going to face
off and there's already been reports
that eff came out a long time ago before
the plot leaked that year on in fact
does attack yar and fian and he does
capture yara and kill once and snake but
now in the leaked insane he kills two
sand snakes so that could be interesting
to see how
that actually plays out as well and
there's photos already that have been
released as well that shows Theon
getting his ass beat by some Ironborn so
I can only think of one or two reasons
why Ironborn would be beating him up and
the first reason would be is because he
allowed Yara to get captured he didn't
try hard enough the saver or two those
could be your Owens men and they're
beating the [ __ ] out of him before they
take him to your own so this all really
starts to make sense when you see the
photos
so that's episode two tell me what you
guys think about that episode how much
of it do you believe to be true or does
all of it sound like [ __ ] to you let
me know there's already been a lot of
photos that have came out after this
leak that is backing up a lot of this
stuff it may not go down exactly the way
this leak is saying it but it's going to
be pretty damn close I think so so far
the leak seems to be pretty legit so
comment below and tell me how you guys
feel about this this episode to seem
true to you or is it just completely
fanfiction thanks for listening guys and
I don't know if I'm going to do a video
tomorrow or not with tomorrow being
Thanksgiving it depends how my day goes
how busy I am but maybe later tomorrow
night I may do episode 3 so just keep
your eyes peeled for that thanks for
listening guys thanks for the support
now see you next time bye